- Is there also differences by
individuals who prefer morning, night,
and then maybe as well, in terms
of not just the hours of sleep,
but the time of the
day in which you sleep?
- This comes back to a concept
biologically well-defined,
called your chronotype.
So are you a morning type, evening type
or somewhere in between?
Depending on the data,
it's about a third/third
split across the population.
I am, unfortunately, just
like the rest of my pedantry,
in terms of personality,
I'm desperately boring.
I am completely vanilla.
I'm a neutral, I'm sort of
like an 11 to 7 kind of guy.
But your chronotype as to when you want
to go to bed and wake up,
it's not your fault, and
it's not your choice.
Because it turns out that
it's genetically determined,
and we now know that there
are at least 9 different genes
that will dictate your
morningness versus eveningness
preference, in terms of being a sleeper,
what we call, are you a night
owl or are you a morning lark?
It's gifted to you at birth.
It's hardwired and it's
very difficult to to change.
And by the way, if you want to
know truly what type you are,
you can go online and you can search
for something called the MEQ, which stands
for the morningness eveningness
questionnaire for chronotype.
And it takes about 3 or
4 minutes, really easy,
and you get your type.
You can also do it in a quick fashion.
You can just say, look, you know
if you or I were on a desert
island, nothing to wake up for,
we could go to bed whenever
we really wanted to,
and whenever we really desired to wake up
rather than when society forces us
to go to bed and wake up,
what time would that be?
And for most people, that time
as to when they would like to go to bed
and like to wake up is very different
than what time they actually are currently
trying to go to bed and trying to wake up,
which suggests that modernity
has inserted a wedge
of a mismatch in terms of our sleep timing
based on our chronotype, because society
is desperately geared towards and biased
towards morning types.
You know, it's this, the
early bird catches the worm.
Those are the people that are praised.
That leaves out in the cold
and chastised wrongly so,
as if it's their choice,
the evening types.
And the early bird may catch the worm.
But I would also say that the
second mouse gets the cheese.
And so, you know, there's, lots of ways
that we should be much
more kind to ourselves
and others in society,
regarding evening types.
The practical part of it
comes to people that I'll see
at my sleep center here who will say,
"Look, I just have terrible insomnia.
I have difficulty falling asleep.
I go to bed and I'm just wide
awake for the first hour.
I just cannot fall asleep."
And then I'll ask them a little bit more
about their chronotype.
And it turns out that they're someone,
who at the weekend finally,
they would normally be going
to bed about midnight, 1:00 AM,
but during the week, because
of their schedule, of course,
and understandably so,
they're forcing themselves
to get into bed at 10:00 PM,
which is a 2 to 3 hour difference,
relative to your natural chronotype.
So no wonder your biology
is not even yet ready
to try and help you fall asleep,
but you are sitting there in
bed just wishing it to happen,
and you can't wish for
sleep to happen and make-
it's not like a light
switch in that sense.
And so it masquerades
almost like what we call
a form of sleep-onset insomnia.
There's also something called
sleep maintenance insomnia.
So do you have difficulties
falling asleep?
Or difficulties staying asleep?
And they're not mutually
exclusive, by the way.
but people with a chronotype
who are night owls,
they can sometimes have that challenge.
They're in bed too early,
and they can't fall asleep.
- That's probably one of
the most important points
to discuss today, because
as a primary care physician,
obviously insomnia, whether
it's the start of sleep
or disrupted sleep, not
being able to fall asleep
afterwards, upon waking in
the middle of the night,
it's easy for me as a
physician to either look
just to lifestyle changes,
talk about sleep hygiene,
discuss caffeine usage, alcohol usage,
things that would impact
sleep from my training level,
and maybe even mental health.
That would be a step further that I go
that most physicians
probably don't even get to
in their 15 minute visits, unfortunately,
in our current healthcare system.
- Yeah.
- But should we be, as physicians,
thinking about chronotype more?
- I think we should
certainly be asking that
as part of the equation and
being sensitive to that,
in terms of understanding it.
It turns out that there's a whole field
of chronobiology and chronopharmacology
because as we've now
started to understand,
drugs can have different
potencies of effect
on the basis of different times
during the 24-hour cycle,
and there may be more
or less potent times for you
to provide that medication.
You know, sometimes for
hypertensive medications
there's some evidence that
time of day is important.
There's a big field demonstrating
that cancer medication can
have a chronotype dependency,
non-trivial in terms of its efficacy.
So I think that that's important.
I also, you know, I love
the way that you think about
not just going to sleep
hygiene, which is critical,
and being mindful of alcohol,
which is no friend of sleep,
and caffeine equally so, and
then moving to mental health,
because what we know is that
perhaps one of the biggest
common central pathways through
which your body instigates
this thing called insomnia
is having an overactive
fight-or-flight stress
system within the body,
which is part of your, the
automatic nervous system.
It's called the
sympathetic nervous system.
It's anything but sympathetic.
It's very agitating, aggravating.
It's the fight-or-flight branch,
Together with something
called the HPA axis,
which is part of your hormonal axis,
particularly regarding a
hormone called cortisol,
which is a stress-related hormone.
And when those things are switched on,
which sort of high levels of
anxiety, worry, and stress
will very much do, sleep
is almost impossible.
And it results in people-
the phenomenon that I would
describe as tired but wired
where they are so desperately tired,
but they're just so, from a
mental health perspective,
to your point, they're just so wired
that they can't fall asleep.
And until you actually
target the treatment
of the mental health component,
it's going to be very difficult to-
I mean, one could just
simply offer, you know,
sedative sleep agents to try
and knock the cortex out.
But we know that there are
increasingly better ways,
and I think one of the
things that physicians
have maybe started doing is becoming aware
of the the current recommended alternative
to sleeping pills, which
is something called
cognitive behavioral therapy for insomnia,
or CBTI, for short.
And I would say that for any sleep, sorry,
for any general physician, any GP,
who is facing a patient who is saying
that they are struggling with sleep,
trying to at first direct them
towards cognitive behavioral
therapy for insomnia
and trying to find a provider for that.
I know it's difficult.
It turns out, if you look
at the number of people
who can provide it,
there is a mismatch
between demand and supply.
There's not enough supply for the demand.
Nevertheless, being aware of
cognitive behavioral therapy
for insomnia is critical.
There are now some apps
that you can use as well
to help with that, to
make it more convenient.
That's the only thing I
would add to that equation.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I'm a big proponent of CBT.
I even have been able to
institute some introductory,
I wouldn't say they're
introductory sessions,
but maybe basic understandings
that I can pass along
to my patients until they're able to see
a mental health provider
about what CBT is,
- Amazing, gosh.
- How it works.
Where we work on thoughts
as opposed to feelings.
Because in reality the
mind-body connection
is so much connected that
we give it credit for
that patients oftentimes are ready to get
a physical diagnosis
and are really surprised
or even shocked when
everything comes up normal.
The imaging, the lab
tests, and it's only until
we get to their mental
health do we figure out
that's where the problem is,
at least beginning and
then showing itself.
So sleep is definitely one of those.
- That's so powerful.
You know, to think that a
physician in this day and age,
and I know, I'm not pointing any fingers,
the job that you have is
so immensely difficult
within these compressed,
zip-file time periods.
You're supposed to go through
this complex biological
organism in front of you,
quickly make, make a diagnosis,
understand the treatment path outcome,
prescribe and get a-
you know, so that someone like you
is being already able to think
about cognitive behavioral therapy,
and then give the stepping
stone components to help them
on their journey as they start
to seek out that further.
I mean, how much better
would the world be, you know
if that was more common practice?
I can't imagine.
- I think it would improve
health outcomes significantly.
That's why I'm a big proponent
of increasing funding
for primary care because the struggle
that a lot of physicians have
is those 15 minute visits
with patients that are unknown to them,
that they don't have a history with.
Like the urgent care model,
where a patient comes
in to see a doctor
they've never seen before,
and somehow in 15 minutes this physician's
supposed to create a
rapport with this patient,
learn about their
condition, their symptoms,
potentially connected
to some sort of cause,
create the treatment, make sure
that the patient
understands the treatment,
that they can afford the treatment,
they have access to the treatment,
and then document that entire
interaction in 15 minutes.
On what planet?
And then make sure the insurance
approves that treatment.
(laughs)
- Right. Right.
You know, what are we, what
are we doing if our goal
is to try to care for other human beings
in the most medically sound way possible.
So you are, I mean,
heroes to keep doing that
and thank you for what you do.
- Thank you.
I appreciate you saying that.